let's now talk a little bit about
the man
who
is the most likely
to replace gavin newsom in california
if the vote to recall him
uh decides to remove him so remember
it's sort of like a two-part vote in
next week's california gubernatorial
recall the first thing is do you want to
remove gavin newsom if the answer is no
that's it it's over newsome stays and
let's hope that takes place if the
answer is yes then there is a sort of
subsequent ballot
um where the question is well who do you
want to replace gavin newsom with the
guy who's leading is a black
conservative named larry elder who has a
long history of disgusting comments
about abortion
about gay rights about so many different
things
he appeared on i guess this is uh yeah
this is the candace owens show
which i guess is part of prageru
dennis prager part of prageru
um and larry elder the guy who if it's
not going to be gavin newsom has the
best shot at being the next governor of
california
said you can make the case that slave
owners should have gotten reparations
when slavery ended let's take a listen
to this together right behind that by
the way when you mentioned that uh the
uk was ahead of us they were do you know
that the slave owners were compensated
after they lost their quote unquote
property the government compensated
slave owners i didn't know that yeah and
so when people talk about liberations
yeah it's fascinating candace is really
learning a lot here huh do they really
want to have that conversation because
like it or not slavery was legal
and so their property their legal
property was taken away from them after
the after the civil war so uh you can
make an argument that the people that
are old reparations not only just black
people but also the people whose quote
property close quote was taken away
after after the end of the civil war
isn't that just amazing guys
now he says you can make the argument
there's lots of arguments that can be
made but shouldn't be made it's sort of
like
we're just asking questions where yeah
it's an innocuous enough phrase but
sometimes the questions you're asking uh
and and the and the questions you're not
asking and the answers that you're
presenting it's all very toxic and
manipulative now by the way
uh slave owners got reparations after
the civil war it's not just that what
larry elder is saying is vile it's not
just that
there could be nothing more retrograde
than electing as governor of california
of any state but of california uh
because that's where we're actually
looking at a recall here um it would be
crazy to put a guy who talks about
reparations for slave owners in the
governor's mansion in california slave
owners got reparations after the civil
war on april 16th of 1862 president
abraham lincoln signed the district of
columbia compensated emancipation act
the law prohibited slavery in the
district and it forced its 900 odd slave
holders to free their slaves and the
government paid the slave owners about
300 per slave that's like 8 grand in in
modern money inflation adjusted now that
wasn't in every
state but we've seen reparations for the
slave owners
and it's all pretty damn crazy now
during this same interview i want to
look at one more clip of this larry
elder also added
black people get longer sentences
but for legitimate reasons he he likes
the fact that there is a sentencing
disparity for the same crimes along
racial lines quite a guy huh
he hired eric holder his a.g who once
said when it comes to matters of race
america has been a nation of cowards
and eric holder has called voter id an
example of pernicious racism right he's
called the fact that blacks get longer
sentences
and they do so for legitimate reasons
that judges take into consideration your
entire criminal history he called that
example pernicious racism right he
called the fact that black boys get
kicked out more often than white boys do
in schools an example of pernicious
racism never mind their behavior this
guy has been a more dangerous race card
hustler in my opinion than even jesse
jackson and how sharp and because
suit and tie
speaks and speaks calmly and people have
much more
um so there it is guys um it is
black conservative quote conservative
candace owens
learning from black republican larry
elder
about why it makes sense that black boys
would get harsher sentences for the same
crimes than white boys this is the
leading alternative
to governor gavin newsom to become the
governor of california so just a
reminder
fortunately
gavin newsom has been pulling away
now leading uh keep gavin leading by
almost 10 points over remove gavin but
everybody in california must vote we're
going to have live coverage of results
to the extent that we get them on the
same day next tuesday and i hope you
will join me for that
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off meaning you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
not a big price tag relative to the
hours and hours of enjoyment i know you
will get from curiositystream
just go to
curiositystream.com pacman the link is
right underneath this video